Kevin McCarthy was just giving some
debate I don't know I guess this was at
the Oxford Union society I guess that
that makes sense he's wearing a tuxedo
otai is a little a skew but he made an
argument
that is the sort of thing you've heard
from every Republican Congressional
candidate for your whole life this is
the sort of thing that they teach you in
how to be a young Republican school and
it's an argument that former speaker
McCarthy made with great Passion the
problem is it's not true peace without
freedom is
meaningless think for one moment it is
human nature that we all crave peace but
we never attain it unless we have
freedom in every single war that America
has
fought we have never asked for land
afterwards except for enough to bury the
Americans who gave the ultimate
sacrifice for that freedom we went in
for but the basis of their basis of
their definition is wrong intervention
is not just
military you see I believe the greatest
strength of America is not the aircraft
carriers is not the Precision weapons
America is more than a country America
is an idea
okay we've all heard
this this is very strong 2010 2011
energy but we've heard this for many
decades now especially from members of
Congress and the problem is it's
obviously false America has fought many
wars for land we fought our first war
from land and we took this land from the
Brits then we fought subsequent Wars for
land we fought Wars for land against the
Indians we I think totally justifiable
Wars we fought a war against Spain and
then we got a lot of land from Spain as
a result of that we fought War we fought
a lot of Wars for land okay and I'm
actually going to be going into that
tonight I'm going to be speaking at
Vanderbilt right here in my own town uh
if you're around I think the speech is
at 8:00 Central it will it'll also be
broadcast on the YF YouTube channel so
you can go check that out as well but if
you're in Nashville come on by we are
going to be defending such
Wars and we're going to be defending
something that's really under attack
these days and it's the notion of
colonialism the the notion of settlement
we just celebrated Thanksgiving I
celebrated it you celebrated it a lot of
Libs did not celebrate it Thanksgiving
is when we give thanks to God for his
many blessings and we commemorate a time
when settlers came over here and settled
this country and and took land from
people in some cases and set up
important alliances and fought Wars in
some cases and then and got the land and
that's the country that we have today
the reason that McCarthy's speech is
frustrating here is one it's so sacaran
we've never taken one square inch of
land from anyone other than to bury our
dead for the totally selfless Wars that
we've fought every single time that's
it's a little sacaran it's a little
overstated uh but the other reason that
this is frustrating is because if this
is if this is really what conservatives
believe about our history then we're
sunk because it means not only does the
left misunderstand history but the right
does as well and so you you now you then
have no party in America that's actually
grappling with with history and that
means also that you're not grappling
with reality and if you're not dealing
in reality ultimately you're not going
to win right now go to jus.com /ns YT
letter y letter T I have got a Christmas
gift idea that is sure to make you the
hero of the season now we all know the
holiday season can be a little bit
hectic the shopping the cooking the long
list of things to do if Fe not because
I've discovered a gift that is both
thoughtful and transformative the gift
of Jus cell skincare from now until
Christmas Jus cell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
our listeners at Jus cell.com NES letter
y letter T treat yourself and your loved
ones to the absolute best skincare in
the world those troubling forehead
wrinkles Fine Lines skin redness sagging
Jael line will disappear right before
your eyes with jus cell's most popular
collection Jus cell promises immediate
effects you will see results in less
than 12 hours guaranteed or your money
back their products use the best stuff
out there on the market the prices are
incredibly competitive and in fact they
will give you special holiday discounts
because they know even if they lose
money on this order they know that you
are going to keep coming back that is
how good it is go to jus cell.com
nsyt get this incredible holiday
discount today every order is instantly
upgraded to free express shipping j.com
YT
today you're not going to be able to
defend against leftwing attacks on
colonization and settlement and this ISM
and that ISM you won't be able to do it
in a way the left understands history
better than the conservatives do
because the left has
For Better or Worse their own
intellectual leaders who I guess just
For Worse well I'm talking about
Communists I'm talking about people like
Angela Davis I'm talking about Herbert
maruza I'm talking about the Frankfurt
School I'm talking about Antonio grami
I'm talking about even more recent
people like uh sa Alinsky I'm talking
about all the all the leftists who
dominate The
Universities do you want to talk about
history I'm I'm talking about Howard Zin
and the so-called people's History of
the United States That's revisionist
History it's a bunch of nonsense in in
the words of of Mitch Daniels former
governor of Indiana then president of
Puro he said it's a bunch of excal trash
that should should be banned from
classrooms true but in order for Howard
Zen in order for the leftists to rewrite
history as they have they had to at
least have some inkling of the real
history in the first place and when
we repeat platitudes nonsense FES like
Kevin McCarthy is saying here we've
never fought any War for any land
whatsoever then we are absolutely
vulnerable to the left-wing intellectual
attacks we are defenseless we have no
way of fighting them them off when the
libs come in and they say America you've
just taken a bunch of land from other
people and the best the conservatives
can muster is no we can't America is not
even a land it's just an idea floating
in outer space we are a pure abstraction
how dare you you and then the libs can
say well okay you're completely wrong
hey how about how about the Spanish
American war how about King Philips War
how about the the Battle of Little Big
Horn what happened after the Battle of
Little Big Horn guys did you just give
the Black Hills to the Lakota Su or did
you take it oh you took it right okay
how about this war how about that war oh
uh yikes H uh well never mind
then hey guys uh if America's just an
idea why do you want to build a wall on
our Southern border uh hm hum hum you
won't have an answer to it it's too bad
I don't mean to knock McCarthy he seems
like a nice guy and this is just what
they teach you in how to be a
Congressional candidate school but it
just isn't true really really weaks
sauce man that was a great clip huh now
hey ring the bell subscribe to the
Michael YouTube channel we'll see you
next time